we need a crazy vato like you in our
game
so with this bandana i welcome you to
the game
yo hold up okay
what's going on hey kalito
uh i was just welcoming eduardo into the
game
why who he what he did
he's he's crazy man we we were thinking
that the game is a crazy guy
yeah i mean this guy is locom eduardo
[Music]
no no i'm the local one in this game
what okay okay check this out
quack quack quack quack i'm a duck
no no no i'm a crazy duck no carlito
solito
okay that's more like you know zany or
or goofy
yeah it's the wrong kind of loco you
want to see loco
tolito you're not crazy
you're like uh the quiet one i'm not
quiet
and never be caught being quiet in fact
i'm always loud check it ah
okay okay that was weird
how much were you yelling i'll show you
local right here
right now in broad daylight yo no no
your pants homes i got telecom on my
underwear
that's the black fish i'm naked and i
don't even know
you gotta pull them up okay there's like
children in this neighborhood okay
okay but check this out i got nine punch
cars
from froyo universe each with a one
stamp in it
every time i get a froyo i get a new
card yeah callito that's just being
cavalier with your finances instead of
collecting your free dessert
i mean that's not local that's just like
financially irresponsible
i might not be local but you know who is
loco
my friend mr basura head
he's dumping the garbage hey i'm the
most local person in here
polito why would you do that okay kalito
okay kalito you don't have to do this
okay
it's not necessary you're not the local
one
check this out
yeah i'm crazy i'm the local one
kalito please don't do it again
stop i'm into d this is like watching
the british version of the office
like it's funny but awkward and sad at
the same time
yes oh well
i think i just proved this bottle is
unbreakable
carlito you're embarrassing yourself
look at this no it's local no no no
carlito what are you going to do with
that i don't know
i'm too crazy
ah kalito why would you do that man that
was local
but not in an entertaining way okay
okay
in the head
now i'm the most local in the game
yes carlito by process of elimination
you are the most local person in the
game yes
that's the most thing i've ever seen
you